no but did we finish the sentence and he
blew sentences on the same in prison um
she blew me she blew presidential prison
but she is uh in because you were
talking i was talking about my life and
my family she is my daughter's you know
main caregiver both my daughters love
her daughter i love her daughter jasmine
she is a huge part of my family uh tt
jerry and um you know great on the
podcast and and has fun and and i feel
proud that you know um she's not i
really believe in my heart mikoroson
that she's not gonna go back to prison
this time because she loves her life she
you know but what did she do in prison
that was bad no she okay sorry that's
the part so she because she was trans
gender gender she would get uh you know
abused a lot she said and there was this
the first big incident she did and again
listen i get it she goes uh this guy
kept walking by her cell and putting his
penis over herself just this flaccid
penis and and she didn't like it he was
like come on come suck this and she was
like no no and then he just kept doing
it kept doing it and she said one day i
was just fed up that he kept putting his
flaccid she said ugly wart filled penis
that's what she said up throw on my
prison cell [ __ ] so i had a can of tuna
i took the top of the tuna can and i
sliced the tip of his dick off right off
i slice his dick up for the tuna can
and i was like listen and she was like i
got two years in the hole for that isn't
that [ __ ] i was like no i get it i
get where you go in the hole for that i
get why you cut his dick off but you're
going to go to the hull for that and she
spent two years in solitary confinement
depends how you look at it see in our as
jews
that's circumcision and that's part of
our ritual yeah that is uh considered uh
yeah
a pastor celebration i'm circumcised a
celebration did i ask i just want to let
you know thank you yeah thank you yeah
to be on the uh to be on the podcast the
other story that you didn't finish was
you were telling your mother that you
were coming on this podcast so you
didn't know what what was that oh i said
to myself when i was walking in i said
chris because my mother's you know
you know she supports me but she's like
you know sometimes your company's a
little dirty i don't like to use found
language i don't like that you sexualize
everything i don't you know i i don't
like that and
you know she's such a big fan of yours
when i told her you know she said it was
like i can't wait to listen so she's
gonna listen to this podcast and i said
when i was walking in do not curse do
not be sexual do not just be clean and
then i immediately just said i want to
splooge on you i you know your mother's
listening now yes okay and so i ruined
it aside from this podcast how does your
mother feel about um
your baby girl's aunt who lives with you
uh blowing son of sam but also taking
care of your daughter i you know i think
my mother in the beginning didn't
necessarily love it
but but now
you know she's on board with tt well
she's on the patreon my mom she's you
know she's on the patreon she's at
patreon.com says christy comedy she
knows the r she knows the real she knows
the real us and and um and she i think
my mom's accepting of it all now um
because the thing is with tt jerry is on
paper he would say oh criminal
blue son of sam slice people's dicks off
uh you know violent
that's on paper no bueno but when you
meet her as a human being you're like
this is genuinely one of the most
beautiful people i've ever met in my
entire life
i trust my children my greatest gifts i
trust their lives with her that's why i
made violet the that's your godmother
and father double whammy violet violet
is the baby i have a baby
jasmine is the girlfriend delilah's my
oldest daughter violet's the baby
daughter so violet and ttt jerry is the
ant it's all our mamas and no the ant
it's all our aunts aunts ants so tt
jerry um uh is you know um just like a
guiding force in in in my life and yes i
do think it is i have you know i like
hollywood now everyone wants to be like
woke check boxes i want lgbtq
representation i want diversity i want
that i just have that naturally
without trying it like i'm just like
you're trying to make this [ __ ] up on
[ __ ] hulu this is just come to my
house come to staten island come over
you're like you're living the insomniac
which is like beyond woke beyond woke
yeah it's an insomniac is the person
that just never sleeps and yet you live
the whole you checked every box that's
how woke i am that's how it works okay
and so and finished so the first offense
in prison was slicing the dick the
flaccid dick slicing the dick off with a
tuna with a tuna fish just tell them
charlie sent you exactly okay yes
so then so we get two years in the hall
for that what can you do come out and
she said life in the hole is is not fun
as you would imagine but it's
interesting to talk to someone who's
really been in it she's like look they
would feed you
you know 6 a.m
11 a.m and 3 p.m you miss one of those
meals you're not getting fed again
until the next day and sometimes they
wouldn't feed you at all for two or
three days in a row because if you did
something in the hole it's anything goes
you're in the bottom basement of you
have a little bit of light you're in the
bottom
you know cells of the of the jail and
that's it so she was like i would have
to like learn how to survive conserve
energy do that for years and then you
don't know what time it is you don't
know what day it is barely shave no
haircuts all those things and so i was
like wow and it's interesting because
me and jasmine jasmine and i were having
problems with our relationship when tt
first came into our life we're having
problems
and
she goes um tt jerry was after a few
months was like you know you two
because i'm observing you two you two
are acting like you're in prison and
you're free you put you're in this
relationship you're putting yourselves
into prison you're getting mad at him
for doing shows you get angry at her if
she questions you you're in a prison
you're not happy she's like you're free
you have freedom he was like i was in
prison i'm telling you
get out of this prison you've created a
mental emotional prison for yourselves
get out of it and we were like holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] we were in prison we were
literally in prison and then jasmine
took that tuna can slice my dick off and
no problems because you can't cheat
without a dick but that is a great
philosophy i love it she's literally
your therapist no jerry's my jerry is
when we talked because and also i don't
know if he ever had the privilege to be
around a person who truly
you know my mom and dad would say you
know there's kids starving there's kids
that don't have theirs just kids that
don't have that it's it's very difficult
to know that because i'm like this isn't
reality that's all right subjective i i
don't know i never understood it i do
yeah where jerry is like i know what
it's like to not to to not have freedom
i know what it's like to think you're
going to die every day so she literally
is a person right in front of me every
day that gets every ounce out of life
every day every second is a gift for her
and i and she's a and so she's so happy
so the most mundane things
is like you know she was cleaning the
dishes one day she was like look at this
look at how beautiful the water is
coming out of that thing isn't it
amazing it looks like a rain forest in
here i was like it's a dirty kitchen
she's like no no this is like a this is
beautiful and i was like wow like
everything she turns around everything
is positive with her everything i love
that everybody's beautiful to have
around your kids too because they
appreciate everything
because i'm that's the biggest that was
the hardest thing about bringing you up
you know because
just in this weird world that i lucky
enough and you're lucky enough to be in
and you have some money and you have
some success and people want to do
things for you and talk to you it's hard
for people to for your kids to kind of
appreciate anything because not everyone
has a tt not ever and my advice to
people out there the fans your fans
listening to the show you've you're in a
rut in your life go out and find a
transgender puerto rican person from the
present day from christmas how are you
going to be wait at the gate they're
coming out every day every day they're
coming and you know what another good
advice if you ever go to prison because
i i don't know if you're going to get
you know you may go to jail one day who
knows a white collar some embezzlement
who knows you you did something right
and and you were gonna go maybe i go too
you know you forget to pay your taxes
whatever we're going to jail okay we're
going to prison all right and and i
asked tt
i said
if i go to jail
what tell me your best advice and you
know what she said and howie this listen
up she said my best advice to you for
real not even kidding around is to
immediately identify as trans in prison
and i said really she goes i was a white
because i go to the safe part of the
jail she goes no the transgenders
they'll beat the [ __ ] out of you she was
like the reason why is because you
you if you don't if you identify as
trans and you don't go to the
transgender part of the prison because
sometimes you don't and you go to the
male part part of the prison
you are literally nobody will mess with
you because you're transgender so if
they beat the [ __ ] out of you then in
prison they beat the [ __ ] out of a woman
and that you can't do that because you i
you're a woman to them to the inmates
right you beat the [ __ ] a woman if you
beat the [ __ ] out of them they lose all
their street cred because they just got
beat up by a woman a jail woman so you
literally nobody [ __ ] with you because
it's a lose-lose for the inmates there's
no incentive so it said
what is tt's second offense in prison
the first one was cutting the dick off
the second offense was um she um
i think there was a incident with one of
the guards that she claimed was uh
abusing him uh abusing her and um she sh
um [ __ ] in a folger's can [ __ ] and
pissed in a folger's can for upwards of
a week and then when he was coming over
one day shook it all up and threw it all
in his face
and that was another and that's not bad
no but then on what happened what the
[ __ ] are you what do you mean that's not
bad
my daughter said that's not bad it's not
cutting someone's dick off it's not the
same thing like you could just wash that
off
wow so now it's a musical yeah so yeah
but but no but the what happened was
with that is that obviously guys
and then jerry got the better of this
guard and beat the [ __ ] out of this
guard so that's what but it was his [ __ ]
her [ __ ] exactly their [ __ ] he covered
it because it you know and i i always
think about that i'm like i mean forget
about getting beat up the case of pink
eye that guard oh
and i'm saying that jeremy who is our
producer here the title of this uh
episode is pink eye and paper cuts
[Music]
bye